hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
unique 2021 science fiction and action
movie featuring ryan reynolds called
free guy
have you ever played or heard of grand
theft auto or gta
the movie takes place in an open world
desktop video game called free city
where players can take part in
action-packed missions like spy jobs or
bank robberies in order to gain money
and level up their characters the
strongest characters in the game are
obviously the ones with sunglasses
because they are controlled by real
players to support the storyline of the
game the developer also created
non-playable characters or we call it
npc
an npc is a character that is not
controlled by a real player instead it
is programmed to do certain daily
activities in the game and of course an
npc cannot die
among the many non-playable characters
in the game there is guy inpc who is
programmed to be a bank teller in the
game and unaware that his world is a
video game
he works and spends most of his time
with his best friend buddy who works as
security in the bank
the pair works in the bank that will
always be robbed by real players and
they always have to play the part of
helpless bank employees as they get
robbed
on the other side there is a sunglasses
character called molotov girl who is
making a deal with another player for a
coordinate of a safe house that keeps a
video that contains top secret
information
later on as guy and buddy on their way
to home they suddenly walk past her guy
seems surprised as she sings the song he
says his dream girl will like
he comments on the song which surprises
the girl because she is used to hearing
all the phrases each npc has to say
because of that guy begins to deviate
from his programming and follows where
the molotov girl goes but unfortunately
he is hit by a train sending him back to
his home and having to start his boring
daily activities again
the next day when the robbery takes
place in the bank guy sees the girl he
met yesterday and starts to rebel
he tries to fight back and manages to
grab the sunglasses from the robber when
he puts them on he finally discovers
many features of the game that
supposedly only appear to real players
he picks up the health boxes to heal
himself and now he is also able to steal
other players money when they die
in the real world keys and mouser who
work at tsunami a company that runs free
city detect guys weird activities and
suspect that he is a hacker who uses npc
skin to take down other players to
resolve the problem they decide to go
into the game as their avatars to
confront guy
thanks to the sneakers from the
sunglasses he manages to jump away
they keep chasing after him guy tries to
escape by grabbing onto a wrecking ball
but he misses and falls
luckily he manages to save himself with
a bubble suit however the employees find
him and hit him with the police car
thinking they have taken the hacker out
for good keys feel something strange as
the number of online players did not
change even after they killed him
indicating that it wasn't a hacker
suddenly an interview of keys with
millie in earlier years is displayed
discovering keys and milly are the
masterminds behind the free city before
antoine owner of tsunami company stole
their original code from life itself
game a game which was originally
developed by keys and millie and used
that code to build free city franchises
surprisingly millie is the player behind
the molotov girl character
millie visits keys and asks him to help
her get evidence of antoine's crimes
because she knows the proof of their
stolen code is hidden in a safe house
which she is going to infiltrate while
playing as molotov girl
later on guy approaches molotov girl
outside the safehouse the house guard
spot them and start shooting at them so
they have to flee
guy offers to help her in her mission
but it is impossible as he is only at
level one while she is already at level
195
guys then starts taking on missions and
pulls off several heroic acts like
returning stolen money and pulling kids
away from traffic because of his
uniqueness players in real life start to
notice him and guy suddenly goes viral
with his unique nickname called the blue
shirt guy he even shows up as an answer
on one of america's quiz show jeopardy
long story short he manages to reach
level 102.
the next day guy comes to the bank and
persuades buddy to join him after
stealing sunglasses from a player who is
doing a heist mission at the bank but
buddy refuses to do so because he thinks
it is too dangerous
antoine realizes the popularity of guy
and wants his employees to keep guy on
the game
additionally the company is also going
to launch free city two in two days
despite not being fully coated and still
contains bugs and he makes it worse by
telling keys that the game is not
backward compatible with the first game
meaning that most of the characters will
not be able to be played in the free
city too
the molotov girl goes back to the safe
house and manages to take the stolen
code
but she is confronted by the house's
guards and gets cornered
out of nowhere suddenly guy crashes
through on a motorcycle and helps her to
eliminate the guards before escaping by
using a hang glider after the event the
two hang out and guy surprisingly
manages to guess the molotov girl's
favorite ice cream flavor which is
bubblegum ice cream
she is impressed because nobody likes
that flavor and he manages to guess it
right it's just like guy knows
everything about this molotov girl they
end up kissing before millie disconnects
from the game
keys finally realizes there is something
strange about the codes of the free
city's npcs
he tells millie that guy is not
controlled by a hacker instead he is the
first living ai which could be able to
decide his own path
this proves that antoine has stolen
their code and implemented it to the
free city because their main idea for
the game was to have the npcs grow and
develop over time as they adapt and that
is what guy's been doing recently he
also warns millie that the current world
of free city will be completely erased
when the free city 2 is launched which
is 48 hours from now
thus they decide to ask guys help
millie goes back to the game as molotov
girl
she reveals to guy that he is just a
character in a video game who does not
exist in real life and he will be
completely deleted if he doesn't help
billy after knowing the truth guy feels
so sad and runs to the beach there he
realizes that something is hidden behind
the beach and he decides to help a
molotov girl
guy then asked buddy to go with him to
the safe house where the stolen code is
kept but surprisingly the guard's real
player is a big fan of guy and is very
excited to meet him he basically lets
guy rob him and take what he wants even
asking god to kill him but guy refuses
the request
he later brings the file to millie
on the other hand guy's popularity has
risen sharply even popular streamers in
real life like pokemane dantdm and ninja
are talking about him
knowing about that antoine gets pissed
off and thinks the guy's presence in the
game will hurt the free city 2 sales
mouser suggests to reboot the system so
that guy will get back to its default
form
in the game guy and millie managed to
access the file showing an island which
proves that anton really stole their
code guy claims that he has seen this
island but doesn't remember when or
where
the game then is successfully rebooted
before he can tell where he saw it to
millie
millie manages to get back into the game
after the reboot but guy doesn't
remember who she is as he is already
back to his default setting she asks
keys for help and he tells her the guy
is created to always be searching for
his dream girl and he just needs
something to help trigger the code
molotov girl decides to kiss guy and it
brings back all his memories including
where he saw the island it turns out
that the image of it is reflected off
the blinds in his apartment because of
that keys figures out that the island is
just hidden beyond the city's horizon
guy and millie then gather all the npcs
in the game and tell them that there is
an island across the city that allows
them to move and act freely instead of
what they were coded to do
the speech inspires all the npcs and
they start to move at their own will
with all the npcs gone the players are
left confused
mouser then shows antwon a recording of
guy and millie taking the secret file at
the safe house antoine then realizes
that millie is involved and orders
mouser to kill them and kick them out
from the game mouser uses his power as
the game developer to destroy guy and
milia's guy is driving them outside the
city with the help of keys a ramp
suddenly pops out and they manage to
escape
they arrive at the beach but keys gets
caught and fired from the company before
he leaves antoine room keys launches his
last help to the pair he creates a
bridge for them so that they can cross
the sea safely
on the other side antoine orders mouser
to boot the game which disconnects
molotov girl and all the players from
the game but keith secretly conducts a
live broadcasting of guy to all free
city players so that they can still be
able to watch him despite being
disconnected from the game
furthermore antoine also commands his
employees to deploy dude a bigger
stronger but dumber version of guy who
is not fully programmed but it is the
final weapon of antoine to get rid of
guy
but he arrives to help while guy gets
tossed around by dude before receiving
the final blow guy manages to pick up
sunglasses and deploy a captain america
shield which surprises chris evans who
is watching it live in a cafe he also
manages to deploy a hulk's fist and a
lightsaber however dude is too strong
and keeps beating guy until he puts the
glasses on dude who now is able to see
the world as guy does and starts dancing
randomly
guy and buddy then start running toward
the island
antoine starts to lose it and brings
mouser to the server room where he plans
to destroy the server and delete the
game entirely
mouser stops helping antoine when he
figures out that antoine was really
stealing the code from keys so antoine
begins to destroy everything with an axe
causing the city environment to be
deleted including the bridge
unfortunately but he can't make it to
the end and is deleted from the game but
he tells guy that he has had the best
day of his life because of guy guy runs
and finally breaks through the barriers
and makes it to the island which is then
revealed to all the npcs and the players
in the real world
millie then confronts antoine in the
server room and makes a deal with him
she will let antoine keep the free city
name for sequels and spin-offs but
antoine has to let her have the original
code of the game and stop destroying the
server
soon free city 2 is launched but the
sale slumped because of numerous bugs
and lagging online play resulting in
antoine being kicked out from the
company on the other side millie keys
and mouser develop free life which
brings all npcs from free city to there
milly then watches a recording of keys
explaining that guy's character is
always going to fall in love with
molotov girl because he created the
algorithm based on key's own love to
millie she realizes this and decides to
approach keys and kiss him
back in the game guy and dude finally
become friends and surprisingly buddy is
brought back to life in the game and
they reunite
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching
[Music]